hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne is
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking it on you I'm just
checking in on you how are you how's it
go I'm actually doing great
despite the that cost I just did it
wasn't a real cop I just you know I've
I've I've run out of unique ways to say
I'm just checking in on you I try to do
it a little bit differently and I got
nothing left I don't know what you want
for me anyways let's get on let's get on
with the podcast here you know this is
just a quick one this isn't even an
official podcast despite the fact that I
have [__] advertising on it it's not
an official one this is me just poking
my head into your little office it's a
little cubicle idea living room if
you're unemployed or maybe you're living
off a trust yeah that's a great big
shout-out to anybody just sitting around
living off a trust you know what you're
going to do today I go down to the art
store get yourself an easel
you know canvas start Peyton that's what
people do you know when you're like
super [__] rich there's no reason for
you to go outside there's there's no
[__] reason I really can't stand when
people judge you know trust fund babies
I feel that's like one of the one of the
biggest issues that this country is
dealing with right now is the harsh
judgement of trust fund babies you know
I mean anybody can be [__] broke and
be like ooh that rich [__] just sitting
over there doing nothing what a waste
what a waste of a [__] life you know
let me tell you that you Subway sandwich
eating judgmental [__] let me ask you
this if you were in that situation what
would you be doing so I could tell you I
would be doing the exact same [__]
thing and all you [__] people on
you're high or it's going on knows what
I could do it you know how are those
people you know people knows people know
me I have to wake up with the purpose if
I don't have a purpose in life shut the
[__] up you had bills alright that's
what you're doing you're walking out to
doing you're chasing the [__] carrot
and someday you're dreaming
you dream that that carrots not
be down you want to be that easel guy
you know look at George Bush man you
ever see a guy enjoying not being
president more than that guy he's
actually good at what he does he's not a
trust fund baby either by the way I'm
just saying you know he's actually good
at it
just sits there I wonder what he thinks
about just there's no way to be present
when you leave as president you have
dead bodies on your conscience whether
you made the right decision of the wrong
decision at some point you had to shoot
off some missiles because who's kidding
who America is the world's babysitter
okay we know what we know what's that
for you
okay and what is best for you is to do
what we say and give us your natural
resources as we pretend to care about
your people okay it's like a Lifetime
movie everybody's acting like something
specials happening at the end of the day
was wasn't that really just a bunch of
[__] so you could [__] make money you
know what I was I have no idea what I'm
talking about I'm talking about trust
fund babies and I'm sick of the judgment
of who judges a baby first of all kind
of a [__] person you maybe that's why
God didn't give you money even think
about that yeah yeah yeah it's called
Karma isn't that the most overused
[__] expression karma this is my
theory on karma karma gets you unless
you unless you don't give a [__] you
don't give a [__] you truly don't
give a [__] you got to add like a level
of guilt for karma to come back and bite
you in the ass
but if you just some [__] entitled
[__] you those people they skate through
life you know you ever see him
you ever seen entitled [__] just walk
across the room it's like he has those
little kids shoes on that have the
wheels on them you know I take two steps
they just glide across the room they
don't care about breaking hearts they
don't care about evicting people right
they don't give a [__] who's [__] so
they're shirt together
I don't what is that endangered species
throw it on the grill they don't care
you know is it genius to that just not
giving a [__] you know I mean I'd love
to see one of those people you know in
the afterlife if you have to get if you
actually get judged just to see the
[__] look in the face you know what I
mean and then God at some point would
have to feel some sort of shame being
like well you know at the end of the day
I assembled that you know what I mean
that's why I've never understood about
the judgment it's just like you know
especially these [__] sociopaths
as opposed to the level-headed saint
that I am these [__] these [__]
sociopaths out there like when is you
know shouldn't you you know shouldn't
you be judging God on that one shouldn't
you be looking up like really you know
well last night you forgot to put the I
give a [__] about other people assembly
into this one just [__] sent it out
there I don't know the more I vaguely
pay attention to all that space [__] you
know I hate people who are into space by
the way I was talking about you
understand and just just hoping you can
keep looking like yeah I get it I get
you know ourselves understand as we
[__] we've seen how gigantic it is yet
we haven't found anything so I still
think this place is pretty amazing it's
fascinating as Mars is there's there's
nothing to do there I don't understand
these [__] people that want to go to
Mars and live there it's like and do
what huh live in some [__] strip mall
for the rest of your life some Star Trek
looking strip mall [__] drinking Tang
just you can say oh yeah you know that's
your big [__] move but you know
people want to live on Mars that means
they suck at everything else in life
right they got nothing you know you know
what it is you graduate high school you
want to come back someday right smoking
a big cigar going eh you know yeah I was
that guy used to push around the
playground but you know what I did right
when I did things I did things and now I
smoke this and I Drive dad and see that
over there that's [__] me admit as I
matter so usually in this day and age
that means you're going to try to create
an app right you're going to [__] it I
don't know get some sort of you start a
website will you curate videos and
[__] news I don't know what these
[__] Millennials do but I think if
you if you suck at that right
you can't play an instrument and you ego
cannot just handle just being happy with
what you have I think at that point it's
like I can't just go back to my high
school reunion just being some regular
joke
waking up in the morning putting my
coffee in my thermos going into the
shower and quietly crying was the water
cascades over my face and my wife comes
walking in going you all right yeah yeah
it's just out I just sneak I'm fine just
washing my face boys my turn all right I
think at some point maybe you just
[__] give in and just say hey man you
know being a regular guy is kind of
[__] cool you know or you can't
handle it right this remind me I've
never seen a few good men you can't
handle the truth you know there's too
many too much gritting teeth in that
movie that's right
Iceman I am dangerous right too much of
that [__] so I never watched it you know
which people walking around dressed and
[__] then little maybe suits anyways
you can't [__] handle it you got to
go back to you high school you got to do
something and I think at that point
that's when you just say listen I I got
to live on Mars yeah I can't go back
with nothing I got to have something to
say that's like Lance Bass he couldn't
handle that Justin Timberlake walked
away from from instinct right ah what is
that
that way whatever the [__] they say
that's somebody go i all i could like
puppets right he just [__] walked
away you know and you got the one guy
the goatee guy he's got a sense of humor
about himself he makes all these funny
commercials he'll do a thing he doesn't
give a [__] right you got the dreadlock
guy didn't used to bang Jennifer Aniston
oh is that the other guy who's some
white guy with dreadlocks used to go out
with Jennifer Aniston you know every one
of those beautiful celebrities always
dates a guy if you always have that bed
then really you got that moment like wow
why don't I learn how to break [__]
play the ukulele with flip-flops that's
what I had to do [__] walking around
you goddamn man tits um anyway sorry I
think Lance couldn't handle it he's just
like what the [__] you know so then I
next thing you know he's signing up to
go out in space to somehow try you I'll
do would you put you put out future sexy
songs huh wait wait wait right
Wang Wang Wang Wang man man I'm going to
outer space
what Oh what is it about wearing your
pajamas in the middle of the day that
just it just [__] opens your mind up
you know what I mean I swear to God
there is no free of feeling to being a
white male heterosexual still in your
pajamas at 11 o'clock in the morning on
a weekday on a weekday and you know what
because I'm a liberal [__] I want
everyone to experience that you know all
the people in the Philippine anyways I'm
actually I'm in a giddy mood because I
did something yesterday that's scared
the living [__] out of me and I didn't
die which is oh you know obviously
because I'm doing this podcast so you
know I hadn't flown a helicopter since
like October until this month and I flew
for the first time and I could not
believe how [__] rusty I was how much
[__] you forget you're like what oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah that's right you know
turn it back
turning final I didn't even slow down I
was so busy trying to keep the [__]
pad between the compass you know and the
dashboard there I can't even with the
[__] he called the control panel that I
forgot I was still doing like 65 knots
and I'm would I [__] went right by it
had to slam on the brakes right so but
you know I flew around she'll check off
the rust I was coming around coming
around you know so I went I I went again
yesterday and I went up with my
instructor and he was like so what do
you want to do I said I let's do the
pattern let's fly the traffic pattern
let's do some autos that's where they
simulate a main rotor failure that's the
big fan above your head like what if all
of a sudden the engine cuts up you know
um and the nose kicks left what do you
do you slam the collective down dad
right pedal right trim air speed rpm
become the rpms coming up you pull the
collective up you catch the [__]
things you pick up your spot so we were
doing those and at some point I was just
like I [__] this I have to fly this
thing by myself or solo as they say in
the business but I'm just a novice so I
said alright because well okay we did a
couple those what do you want to do now
I said alright can can you just step out
and let me just fly this thing around
one time by myself just to do it again
and he goes yeah absolutely so he steps
out it up it to that point it's been a
great day you know not a lot of traffic
over there everything's [__] fine so
he gets out roll it back up you know
lights are out rpms you're in the green
gauges roll green car beret Heat's off I
[__] lift up light on the skids bring
it up boom hold on a hover here we go
here we go cyclic wait for it wait for
it let's wait in the [__] thing you
know [__] palms are sweating you know
there's always that god I can't believe
I actually [__] know how to do this
thing right
so immediately there's a [__]
crosswind so I'm looking at the wind
sock about how you [__] contemn fight
it less pedal now I'm facing when so
everything's fine and next thing you
know like [__] like three JetBlue's I
taken off at Southwest is landing you
know I made my call and the guys like
you know what
have a [__] 6 Victor Hotel standby
standby means shut the [__] up I always
forget that cuz then I would go six
routes to hotels standing by let's go
I'm [__] sitting there I felt like I
was in a hover but 20 minutes what I
really wanted to have happen it was just
like one of those things was like
alright [__] this up feeling this rolled
out have him step out I [__] roll
back up lift it up ask for Clarence he
gives it to me and I just take him for a
lap around the airport that's all I
wanted to do so now I'm [__] sit in
the tub or just going Jesus Christ now
I'm thinking what the [__] am i doing so
finally he called yeah [__] go six
Victor hotel left close traffic clear
for takeoff clear for takeoff six victor
hotel and then I'd [__] you know took
off brought it around and when I was
turning across when you know I'm looking
for traffic to join the downward make
sure I don't have any problems I was
actually thinking like you know last
night I did stand up dressed as Steven
Adler at the goddamn comedy gym I tried
out a new [__] bit about blow-up
dolls that was killing so hard I looked
over and Josh Adam Meyers was [__]
dying laughing on the side of the stage
and so as much as you make people laugh
when you look over and you see a fellow
comedian dying laughing you know you're
onto something so then I went back and I
got to play rhino sore dressed as Steven
Adler the sound guy now I would have
dressed up as Matt camera but he's just
you know he doesn't have any unique
facial hair he's got that sort of that
Luke Skywalker haircut I just want to
look like me with a stupid wig on you
know and then I got to play the encore
Paradise City and I was thinking I
[__] did that did stand up and play
drums live last night okay right now I
am flying a helicopter by myself and I
flunked so much [__] in high school
terrible at math [__] flunked French
all of that [__] was a great feeling
and I was like oh yeah that's right I'm
flying a helicopter so I get to the
downward you know where you go across
3-0 you bring your [__] carburetor
heat up see if your [__] carburetor
doesn't freeze over and the engine
doesn't cut out as you're slowing down
came around still pullin power kept my
60 knots as I turned the [__] bass
into file
okay righted landed set the thing down
nicely and that my instructor came back
in and gets you know plug his headphones
in he goes he goes out of that feel I
said I you know I said it was like
riding a bike except you could kill
yourself he started laughing and what I
found with instructors is they're all
badass guys every one of them checks
they're all [__] badasses you know
but the second you admit that you're
actually scared they always laugh and
then they usually tell you a story how
[__] nervous that they were but if
you're some [__] cocky [__] you don't
want to do that because then what
they're going to do is they're going to
chop throttle on you as you're [__]
doing some say yeah I don't need that
even though it's good training I've
never had anybody do that to me
but anyway so I did it and it made me
feel [__] amazing that it's just like
the sickest goddamn feeling and I swear
to God all I need to do is make like
another forty million dollars and I
think I could actually afford to truly
engage in that hobby I in LA it's just
super expensive I think if you live more
in the middle of nowhere it's a big
[__] thing is like just storing the
goddamn whatever you get the plane of
the helicopter I don't know if anybody
knows like a cheap way to do it
I would absolutely absolutely do it but
until then I'm just treating it like the
way I treat cars like I just go on the
road you know I go to budget and then
that's it I just whatever [__] car
they give me I get it I gotta be honest
with you I bets the one thing that bugs
me about renting helicopters it every
time you [__] go in there something's
a little different you know just be nice
to know you [__] tail number not have
to [__] constantly be looking or the
control panel know where everything is
know how everything works everywhere
seems to be a little bit different it's
just like a [__] it's just that extra
thing you got to like deal with that I
wish I didn't and I'd love to just buy
one of those [__] r22 you know that's
fun is help they're just a little
[__] two-seater right and you're
really flying it it's like if you had a
car that just had drum brakes and no
power steering like you really [__]
you know are holding up this is just
what I've heard from other pilots
because I've never flown anything fancy
nothing's fancy like but I really
[__] enjoy it and just even doing
that I mean that how long it takes to
fly the pattern I mean that couldn't
have been more than like felt like 90
seconds we probably maybe was a little
bit longer I don't know but I don't know
it's just [__] definitely left the
place yesterday you know that's one of
those things where you did something
great you're driving away and you get
the window down just driving I going so
anyways you guys been watching the
playoffs I'd say four first round
playoffs I tell you this series I'm
watching obviously then I'll say I'll
tell you again I'm just going to keep
saying I'll tell you I'll tell you I'm
watching those Celtics in the boat
Celtics are now up three games to two
after being down Oh - after looking like
we had no [__] answers right and
which is why my nod for MVP of the
series is Rondo without a doubt because
the second he went down the series just
completely changed and I thought all of
the Bulls had us figured out but
evidently it was Rondo he knew what the
[__] was going on I'm giving him full
[__] credit because it's just it's
been a Tale of Two Cities
you know it looked like they were going
to sweep us and now it looks like we're
going to run the table on them however
how I think Rondo is coming back
he took his cast off his suits have long
sleeves again and I can't wait to watch
Game six I want to see like if this guy
is good is it
here's in this in this series and last
night admittedly the officiating was a
little subpar and it definitely went in
the Celtics favor and I loved when Lopez
was applauding the [__] ref sometimes
it's worth getting a [__] technical I
love that guy man that guy comes out
every night wants to play he's a little
[__] weird he's on his own vibe he
just I really like that guy I love when
he [__] started clapping like my
favorite thing and then they go to I
think it actually worked because then we
went down they called the ticky tack
foul on the other end and you saw Dwayne
Wade was whatever the Celtics said to
him I think it might have been Isaiah he
just started smiling and laughing I
swear to god man I just think the NBA is
so [__] controlled I really do just
sort of simple fact that you can do it
I've said this a zillion times there is
no easier game to control or fix than
basketball because it's the only [__]
game where you can sit down as a ref you
can take people out of the game you know
I mean I guess all the games you can
eject somebody but they you know in
baseball football hockey you really have
to do something you just can't point it
again be like hey go sit on the [__]
bench
I'll get you can in hockey right I don't
know you know what that's what else
things what you think you have a good
theory then you [__] explore all the
options you're like well maybe doesn't
work
whatever now if you only sit it down for
like [__] two minutes and they come
back out it's not like well [__]
Wayne Gretzky's got three penalties two
more and he's out of the game right hey
you all back on track with my theory
there you go you can't spit Tom Brady
down all you got it like this is what
kills me about basketball I don't give a
[__] how many points you're up you're up
like 20 points okay this games a rep
it's one quarter to go you know most
teams are lucky if they score like 27
and a quarter that's like a [__]
great quarter we're up by 20 all we
really need to do is score eight points
and we're fine and the next thing you
know it's just like the [__]
jerk-offs are out of 20
that will run every [__] time that
whole thing it's a game of runs I don't
think it is I think it's a game of
[__] ratings and if a team gets up
too high they just start [__] call
calling files together to as it's stupid
it's a stupid [__] theory but it
doesn't it just appears that way maybe
it is the nature of the game that nobody
can just blow somebody out they always
come back like I would say like 85% of
the time of course I didn't do any
research but it seems like 85% of time
you [__] go you go up like 30 points
in the first half you know somehow by
the end of the game one away what else
sex
well most unbelievable improbable
comeback since last night's [__] slew
of NBA games that did the exact same
thing anyways I don't want to talk about
all I'm saying is that I think Rondo
really showed I mean just I mean it's
[__] unbelievable like how much the
series changed one guy is gone and the
whole thing turns around so I'm excited
to watch Game six even if they win I
mean I like seeing greatness I don't
give a [__] I mean I hope it's on my
team but if it isn't that I can't and I
can't just sit back and appreciate it
right I try to be a good guy right now I
don't know why I have this [__] this
pillow that wraps around you this little
half circle pillow you know when you
have a baby abused it's perfect you set
them down you're giving that bottle of
Jack you know and then that's it you
know but if you try to do it with
regular pills it doesn't work but for
some reason I have it around me right
now
it feels right like I don't wait to have
a kid to buy one of these [__]
semicircle pillows all right what else
did I want to talk about I've been
watching you know I've been watching the
hockey okay gotten over the fact that my
Bruins have been knocked out by the
quietest fan based team in the league
right the team that cheering forgot
until April then also they all show up
like they give a [__] about man that was
[__] hard watching that anyways
the Predators are looking great but I
still think I don't know if I already
talked about this I started this podcast
twice forget if I brought this [__] up I
still I'm still going with the Penguins
I think the Penguins repeat and I miss
Anaheim Edmonton I bet that's a great
[__] series - it's so crazy they
already down just two series in each
conference so I have to make sure that
I'm watching for those people last week
you like hey how come you didn't talk
about MotoGP the race in Austin you know
what I didn't see it and then I realized
I recorded it and this is what you
learned if you're new to MotoGP and you
go to record the race and you got to
[__] do it it might it might be
better than Formula One just because of
the sheer amount of like passing and
lead changes and all that it's [__]
insane
and then the fact you just watch these
guys falling off motorcycles I brought
one of the races on well let me explain
it first you're going to go to record it
if you novice like me you go to record
it and you'll be watching like the first
race and it will say moto two and
they're on these little skinny bicycle
tires and you're like those don't look
like the [__] you know those badass
bikes that I saw what's going on here
then there's moto three and you're like
what is the real one was that Rossi
Valentino Rossi guy whatever [__] his
name is Mike in the mechanics whatever
that other guy's name is I don't know in
the [__] name shed so there's three
different classes this is what I learned
all right on
MotoGP as they say and this moto two
there's moto three and there's MotoGP
and that's basically like being in
double-a triple-a and then being in the
majors now for whatever reason moto
three is the lowest level so I guess
they go in three two one
I guess that's how they do it and they
don't say one they just say GP which I
believe stands for Grand Prix I don't
[__] enough so motor three is 250cc
according to this thing on red Adair -
250 cc bike you know so that's basically
cubic centimeters so it's a smaller
engine it's not as fast you know it's
still fast - [__] the way they're doing
it but you know that's the one like okay
alright there grab
Chopra will you know we'll see how you
do at this level and then if you succeed
at that level then they move you up to
moto 2 which is 600 cc's evidently four
strokes and all the engines are made by
Honda which I find interesting
so hunt they're all Honda based
everybody's working with the exact same
[__] that's probably so they can truly
get an idea of who who is the best rider
who's going to get called up to the show
MotoGP and according to this person a
lot of times in moto moto 2 the race is
better because they all just have
basically the exact same engine so this
guy was saying you could fit you can
usually can throw a blanket over the top
three people in that race and then the
big show is MotoGP which is a thousand
CCS and those things are just [__]
rockets and I watch this whole thing on
how they build them the hand-built gets
how much those motorcycles cost apiece
take a wild guess like for some reason
you went down they said hey you want to
take it for a lap but if you [__]
trash this thing you got to pay for it
ok and they give you that [__] suit
with the airbag and fortunately you
don't high siding you slide off the bike
and you get up me like [__] what's that
going to cost me I would have thought
anywhere between 100 and 250 grand you
know and I understand that it's a
[__] racing bike and all that but you
know there little last things you know
what I mean you go to do a build on a
car there's like [__] people working
on it on the other side you can't even
see him a motorcycle I mean it's right
there everything is right [__] there
you and another guy can lift up the
engine [__] is small those like 100 100
250 grams what I would have guessed 375
tops right this is like I'm at the
showcase showdown on The Price is Right
and I horrific Lee underbid is what
happens those bikes cost two million
dollars each
two million dollars each they're
handmade all this space-age stuff i
watch this whole thing on how they built
them the gas tank is actually underneath
the seat what's where the gas tank
usually is is the fuel injector
there's an airport right in front of
that right with a [__] front light
usually I just want to I watched the
whole goddamn thing was absolutely
fascinating and I'm totally in on that
sport watching that sports and I'm
watching the f1 I don't know when the
next race is but if you want to watch do
well I think was the Moto 2 race the
last one this [__] guy came out of a
turn his back end started fishtailing he
went like right up and over the
handlebars doing I don't know how fast I
don't I don't get how they get up
because he landed on like his foot he
limped for a second and then he just
kind of just shakes it off there like a
Ted foot problems said foot problems in
the pit I imagine you had everything
problems you fall off a bike you know
it's funny when I was thinking about
getting a motorcycle out here the
stupidest thing you could ever do you
know riding a [__] motorcycle and a
lot of guys say well you just [__]
flew a helicopter it's which way safer
way state but there's nobody up there I
was actually driving back I was did on
Marc Maron's podcast promoting season
two of efforts of family I don't know
when that's coming out and thank you to
Marc Maron forget me on his podcast had
a great time we talked about anger
meditation we talked music and we help
promote me help me promote the show and
I was on my way back it was the middle
of the day and all of a sudden there was
just all this horrific traffic and this
big [__] accident this truck had
jumped the median strip down oh it's a
guy meaning strip I don't the guy
[__] fell asleep or whatever but ten
people went to the hospital one person
died and a dog died you know so I don't
I just think the highway is way way way
more dangerous I've said it before
you're flying in formation it's like
you're in the [__] Blue Angels
everybody's doing 80 miles an hour
there's no radio contact
nobody knows where anybody's [__]
going there's people texting there's
people on meds you have no idea and then
forget it and then right on the other
side is another group of [__] people
you know there's never-ending parade of
[__] people flying on the other side
you don't know what they're going to do
that [__] guy was driving a truck
fell asleep had a heart attack whatever
the [__] he did jump the meeting strip
went right up and over into oncoming
[__] traffic it like it was like 12
in the afternoon look it up it's on was
on the five right near Colorado
Boulevard so anyway so I was thinking
about getting a motorcycle when I was I
was looking up those MotoGP suits which
are like 2,500 bucks a whack but they
got a little airbag in them and I'm like
well that's what the [__] I would want
there be hilarious to buy one of those
in the buy like a [__] Harley
Davidson and just look like the biggest
[__] [__] ever you just ride that
thing and somebody cuts in front of you
you just late but there's another thing
too it's on those when they're racing
you can lay it down and slide and
[__] all that stuff and you're fine
you're fine it's not like you can slide
into oncoming traffic and there's a good
goddamn garbage truck coming at you I
don't know but I miss riding motorcycles
so I'm thinking uh I'm happy
it's just nothing safe about them I was
thinking all right well I'll just get a
dirt bike I won't go over jumps or
anything I'll just ride some trails but
then ever you have every like [__] I
don't know seems like every six weeks
you hear a story about somebody riding
on a trail choosing a mountain bike
though but if you're riding like a dirt
bike at some mountain line ends up like
bouncing on your back it's got the
helmet on I don't know you know what
this podcast was going great it just
went off the rails somewhere I got
really nowhere let's let's do a little
bit uh advertising indogene Oh
indogene oh the sting read the Gordon
Sumner read it don't try to talk about
how every man looks better in a suit you
know when I'm checking out guys at the
outdoor mall I'm like you know I'm
really attracted to that guy but he's
just wearing an Izod you know with some
corduroys that's not Mall now look at
that fella wearing the suit now there's
something I could take home to my
parents that's it everybody you're sick
of gay men not giving you the [__]
once-over
or maybe rolling their eyes you ever
think that maybe it's not you [__]
love handles maybe it's the fact that
you don't have on a shirt a tie in a
sport coat
to cover up all the mistakes you've made
with your nutrition over the last 40
years thank god this Indo Chino is
making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit and an incredible price
you can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your
suit just the way you want it whether
it's for work
a wedding or another special occasion
here is how it [__] works visit a
showroom or shop online no calm pick
your fabric choose your customizations
from lapels depletes to jacket linings
and more submit your measurements place
your order and wait for it to arrive in
just a few weeks then they'll sell all
this your measurements and all edge
they'll sell all of that [__] to these
[__] nerds making robots - next thing
you know there's going to be a knock at
the door and all of a sudden you're
going to be looking right at yourself
the robot version you wear in this suit
you wanted and that thing is going to
get it you're going to give up your back
it's going to [__] choke you out in
no matter how much you tap out those
robots don't care but this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for three hundred and eighty nine
dollars that's right at indochina calm
when entering BRR at checkout that's 50%
off the regular price from made to
[__] in measure premium suit 3 a 9
bucks is not a premium suits a nice suit
that Indochina docked at Indochina Calm
promo code BIR for any premium suit for
3 and $89 and free shipping incredible
deal for a suit that will fit you better
than anything off the rack ever cooked
yet 3 and 89 bucks actually for a
[__] fitted suit is going to be great
you can walk into an Applebee's and
every chicken there's going to think
you're a banker you got to do it next
thing you know right you're [__] you
know you're ramming away trying to block
up the smell of that bloomin onion that
she's been carrying around all day
[Laughter]
alright lift everybody you know about
lift right it's the app that gets you a
ride in minutes on-demand 24/7 for less
than the cost of a cab
every lyft driver is fully vetted
through their ten-point safety standard
including criminal and DMV background
checks unlike those other people with
that other thing that rhymes with mover
right you don't know what you're going
to get right you can walk in there with
a bloody axe those [__] [__] for
hire
you know you'll get around quickly and
safety with with lifts lifts drivers are
rated after every ride so only the best
thing around you don't have to worry
about getting into a filthy car with
some creepy dude everybody doesn't get a
ribbon at lift the way they do over it
mover with whisk you can tip in the app
which obviously leads to happier drivers
I mean not a tenth lift riders get a
perfect five-star rating from the
passenger it's just a better way all
better all-around experience bigger
isn't always better
lift isn't the biggest ride-sharing app
but it is the fastest-growing and is
rated one I'm talking quality over
quantity thanks to lifts you can get
it's an easy way to avoid drunk driving
you never have to bum a ride well what
if you're on heroin it's another way to
to avoid nodding off in public now
you're in the cab nobody knows and you
know what a lot of people are actually
getting rid of their cars and relying on
lyft to get around and evidently I don't
blame them what do you do in the
apocalypse when the zombies come you
think you can [__] call lift that
lyft drivers getting the [__] out of it
right now lips is offering our listeners
a special deal get three rides up to ten
dollars each next a $30 value in case
you can't do basic math when you enter
promo code bill burr just download the
free lyft app today and enter the promo
code bill burr in the payment section
you'll start with three free rides up to
ten dollars each that's up to a $30
value that's promo code bill burr B I ll
be URR no space all caps all right how
many more of these [__] thinks oh
Jesus all these are quick he's a quick
let me tell you some of Dollar Shave
Club up side and simply safe they
respect the fact that I'm not good at
reading out loud so these are three
quick paragraphs here we go running the
table just like the Celtics on the Bulls
second Rondo sat down Bam Bam Bam 3 2 2
Celtics re Dollar Shave Club is the
smarter choice you'll get a great shade
at a great price conveniently delivered
I D adore you do you no longer have to
schlep to the store to buy a cheap
disposable razor razor that gives you a
cheap shave or spend a fortune on raises
with gimmicky shaving tech you don't
need and when you use Dollar Shave
club's an executive razor with the
executive razor comes with the date rape
drug in the [__] handle some creepy
banker walking around his gold tote
stocks shaving his nuts now that's not
what you do that's a different rig sorry
the Dollar Shave club's executive razor
with their doctor copies easy shake the
blade just gently glides giving you a
smooth shape dr. Carr V shea butter is
transparent for a more precise shave
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps make this not a choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time new members can get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of their doctor cavity only five dollars
with free shipping and after that the
razors are just a few bucks a month
there's no hidden fees and no
commitments cancel anytime you want
join the club today at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / all right up
side it sounds like a date movie right
you want to go see upside the downside
of the upside you want to go see that
stars Tom Hanks Meg Ryan q [__] let me
get a hooker whatever the [__] his name
was who's that English guy used to go
with elizabeth berkley Thank You
Jacqueline he's the guy who has to eat a
whole chicken every day to become
Wolverine I don't remember
Hugh Grant - when you ready you bet you
be great
you ready get the [__] hook girl hey
I never judge that guy
we got a hooker why why wouldn't you why
wouldn't you what else you gonna do what
else you gonna do what go home and make
some [__] Jiffy Pop you [__] Hugh
Grant me crushing you're a [__] movie
star in your own country you go across
the pond
you know who's kidding who England is
like moto
moto3 [__] America is MotoGP that's
what you want to have your hit movies
you guys all know it's true Christ
you're all still in our blue jeans you
all give you your you hate us but you
love our culture it's been it's safe to
say that I'm [__] with actually moon
to the [__] genes company all right
up side there's a better way for you to
buy business travel it's called upside
calm every time you buy a trip at upside
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon card worth
hundreds of dollars
upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotels together
for one low price that's what they do
they rip the seats out of a commercial
airliner and they just stuff you in
there you know you might think flying
standing up like you're at a mosh pit
for six hours from New York to LA might
suck yeah talk to me when you not only
cost you forty bucks no that's not what
they do
bundle pricing saves money this is what
they do if you're a frequent business
traveler your company saves a ton of
money and you can get thousands a year
in gift cards just for buying your air
and hotel together an upside you just
[__] said this plus you still get
your miles there what I feel like in the
end of this you're going to be missing a
kidney this seems like too good a deal
and I get a gift card and I get to keep
my miles and I save them a bunch of
money if you're shopping for business
travel it would be crazy not to check
out upside calm you're out of your mind
it just takes three minutes to see how
much you can say by buying your flights
and hotels together for one low price oh
I see they both cut side deals with each
other somebody's got to be doing you
know at some point somebody gets sold in
the [__] sex slavery here this is
just too good a deal and right now the
human trade right and right now when you
use my name bar you're guaranteed to get
at least a $100 Amazon gift card your
first trip that's my name bar to get at
least $100 Amazon gift card free say big
on travel and get a big gift card every
trip I love upside calm evidently upside
calm minimum purchase required see site
for complete details right here's the
last one every
it simply states if you're not there
when a fire starts simply states can be
there to save your home autos instead of
[__] throw you into it I wasn't there
but we'll put you right back in it
it's kind of a good thing if you're not
there when the fire starts right simply
say it can be there to save your home
all right this is a robot that has a
fire extinguisher what is this
we simply say home security you'll get a
24/7 connection to dispatch and
lightning fast responses times and
emergencies all right I have to look up
dispatch what is dispatch all I know is
I've 24 [__] 24-hour access to
dispatch dispatch comm that's not what I
wanted that's not what I wanted that's
not what I wanted once you wish there
was like voice command on these things
then you could be to be like what did
you want what did you want for [__]
sakes it'll load eventually I'll tell
you what that means later dispatch oh
here it is
it is a send-off Christ what just
happened come on now that's the load
again send off to destination or for a
purpose deal with the task the sending
of someone or something to a destination
for a purpose so they're going to send
somebody who has a purpose and left to
your house when it's on fire they're
going to walk up the street holding
their [__] head high imagine that
person would you know be driving a fire
fire engine right all right the system
is easy to use and completely wireless
you can install yourself in under an
hour no installation guide drilling
holes in your walls no ugly wires simply
say founder and chief engineer thought
of everything when he built this system
backup batteries for your base section
station sorry a cellular connection to
the authorities there are no long-term
contracts no commitments and no hidden
fees simply saves round-the-clock
professional security monitoring it's
just $14.99 a month order today and
you'll get a special 10% discount go to
simply faith bird comm that's s impl I
sa Fe BER com4
10% off your home security system simply
safecom simply safer comm sorry
alright is that it is that it I think I
talked about everything right yeah I
believe I kid everything that I want to
talk but you know I was just checking in
on you here some [__] music you think
that you guys can listen to and we got
another like half-hour of stuff from
classic podcasts from a Thursday or a
Monday and a year a day a week gone by
that's it go [__] yourselves I believe
there's another f1 race this Sunday
check it out if you can
let's go Celtics hoping for a classic I
hope we win but I also want to see Rondo
come on and do is think too you know I
mean I still love that guy he's so is
Celtic to me all right that's it have a
great weekend you [__] and I'll talk to
you on Monday
[Music]
No
ayuh what the [__] I'm talking about we
decided to have a [__] party for a
new place you know you think that was my
idea
do you think it was my idea to have a
bunch of strangers coming to the [__]
house all that people over that's what I
do
hey you want to come over and watch the
game nine people that I know right have
all your [__] phone numbers you know
Nia is a more open person so she's like
let's have a party
all right so we search goes invite your
friends so I'm all right so you know I
got you know I'm a I'm a guy I don't
have a bunch of friends okay I got six
good friends for that I could really
trust you know it's about it at least
out here I'm gonna over here Nia talking
to her mom about all excited about the
party and she's like yeah I sent it out
of what's Facebook and I was just like
oh my god did I just invite a hundred
and ten people and my heart literally
sank going please tell me you didn't
just invite 110 [__] people she said
don't worry they're not all going to
show up it's like yeah but like a third
will and then they're gonna bring people
that you don't even [__] know and
that's exactly what happened it was a
[__] great party I'm not gonna lie to
you but I got to admit like I got to
learn how to UM be I thought I was going
to be a good host I was and I wasn't I
was all right with the people I knew but
the people I didn't know actually most
of them are alright but there were a
couple of them died just fine I just
said there's something [__] annoying
about somebody you don't know sitting on
your goddamn couch you know eating your
food drinking your booze you know who
the [__] are you and somebody else was
laying down on the floor I felt like the
kid's dad when they can get a [__]
job alright it's over
you 26 you [__] bum so anyway so the
party's going great and I'm basically
the whole time you know not drinking too
much but I'm standing by the front door
because that's the only way out alright
and nobody's walking out with any of my
[__] right I'm acting basically like
psycho and [__] stripes
how I am it's how I'm wired alright so
[__] three-quarters way through the
party everything's going great now Mike
well it's just yeah you know I forgot I
forgot I'm not 21 anymore I'm [__] 43
all my friends are adults and
everybody's drinking responsibly and no
one's really hammered nothing got broken
everything's cool so start just as I was
starting to relax some kid comes up to
me he's like yay day you own the house
and I'm like well the bank owns it I'm
[__] paying it off what can I do for
you and he's like yeah it's kind of
embarrassing but I used the bathroom
downstairs and it's clogged now and I
was wondering if you had a plunger and I
was like yeah I do have a plunger I got
a plunger right here the upstairs
bathroom so I give it to the guy and I
and I say man I appreciate your honesty
goes no problem he goes downstairs he
takes care of it
comes back once again he goes he goes
sorry about that I said not at all not
at all what the [__] to toilet
you know clogs up everyone swab I
appreciate appreciate your honesty you
know because that would have been nasty
good for you right so uh another couple
hours goes by the party ends and there's
like one straggler left and I tell the
story to me I'm like you know what it go
with a good guy what a good [__] no pun
intended you know we could have left it
in there and then they you had a party I
come walking in my [__] bathroom
looks like a goddamn Port Authority bus
station toilet you know so psyched so so
one of the strands of the party goes
yeah he goes I saw that whole thing go
down that's not exactly how it went down
like what he talked about he goes he
goes it wasn't him that was in the
bathroom and I go who was it was his
girlfriend some way took a dump of a
magnitude that it wouldn't go down the
toilet
so now she's in there panicking and this
is when today's technology kicks in she
can head back in the day she would had
to crawl out the [__] window and hope
nobody saw her and just left the door
locked everybody would have panicked
holy [__] who's in there did somebody
pass out
if somebody committed suicide some of
what it kicked in the door all right
knocked it off the [__] goddamn
hinges and you go in there there'd be
nobody in there you'd feel the air from
outside and then look down and everyone
would see a giant [__] and be like ah
and the party would be over and the
owner of the house would be walking
around going oh you better drive away
right that's how would it ended but
because of today's technology not saying
she didn't panic you know it's even
worse as a lady because they're not even
supposed to do stuff like that right and
she was able to text her boyfriend and I
would [__] pay at least $400 to read
those texts the panic in those texts and
to his credit he [__] he he stepped
it up he took the hit he came up to me
vh1's I love the 80s own Bill burr and
said I took a dump in your toilet to a
magnitude it didn't go down and I need
the tools required to alleviate this
situation so anti douchebag of the week
that guy right there so taking a [__]
bullet for the team that kid that right
there is the reverse Peyton Manning
award he didn't [__] ago we had
protection issues right now
he took one he took one for the [__]
team went upstairs like a goddamned
gentleman as for a plunger gave it to
him it was all fun and I went down there
at the end of the party you never would
have known anything anything happened
yet I mean like you know three hours
after the Kennedy assassination I bet it
was you as om say it you know marked it
all up and everything was all figured
out it but it was a nice road again
mopped up the brains what am I talking
about
[Music]
go ahead
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday April 20-something 2009 I don't
know what the [__] it is you know I
really don't I really don't all right I
feel like [__]
I had a really rough weekend in Columbus
Ohio but before I get into the details I
want to thank everyone who came out on
Friday Saturday and Sunday I had a great
time I had too good of a time let's put
it that way
um yeah too good a time so good a
[__] time and I'm paying for it right
now
you know I don't know why I keep doing
this I don't know why I just can't learn
you know you know I always do overrated
underrated on this [__] well you know
what's [__] underrated eight hours
sleep you know you know what's you know
what's [__] underrated going eh you
want another shot at Jameson you know
what no I think I've had enough you know
what I would like I would like a water
that's underrated you know not going to
[__] Steak and Shake at 3:00 in the
morning that's underrated get one of
those [__] double burgers I never
even ate at that place before it didn't
even look like meat like a patty you
know what a patty looks like sure we all
do we've all had a [__] burger even
you little veggie [__] out there you
know what it looks like there's a little
burned up wig and there was two of them
you know what kind of a 40 year old
[__] guy going to be 41 and [__]
June goes to Steak and Shake at 3:00 in
the [__] morning when he's got a
goddamn [__] 8:40 in the morning
flight why would you do that sure bill
you suck at math we all know that but
you can tell time I know there's numbers
involved of Jesus Christ
what a [__] idiot this whole [__]
day yes I just started thinking about
that Boogie Nights I'm a [__] idiot
I love [__] ya Eddie and I'm a
[__] Eddie I'm a [__] idiot
twice Friday night ended up at Steak and
Shake at 3 in the morning you know
[__] Sunday night it was a surprise I
didn't walk in they weren't like norm
like on cheers areas again all
shit-faced Jesus Christ what a [__]
motley crew you want to see a motley
crew go to a [__] steak and shake at
3:00 in the [__] morning good God
Almighty
now I'll tell you I was part of the
problem oh you know I bet I was doing
that everything else was doing they'll
sit in there shit-faced looking around
everybody else going Jesus Christ look
at look at that [__] guy oh my God
look at her Jesus she went slippers
Jesus Christ you know you don't even
realize they're doing it to you to that
[__] guy oh look at that look his
[__] eyes what does it's almost like
he's been drinking jameson all night why
wouldn't you get a water after a while
what a [__] idiot yeah let me have
one your burnt up wig [__] burgers
why is [__] food so good when you when
you're shit-faced you know is that what
it is shit-faced [__] food is just all
[__] [__] [__] decisions I didn't
want to do that man I was doing well you
know I went to Trader Joe's
you know dodged a bunch of [__]
Burgin stock hippies and I you know I
went in there and I oh I I got the
fridge put in my room
[__] global warming I want to be in
shape I had a fridge put my room I like
I had got all this healthy food what do
i do what do I do I go out I go drinking
two out of four nights like a [__]
more oh my god I went to this one you
know what I had a bite a slice of pizza
last night - that's how [__] up I was
this is like all coming it's like a
slide show you know you can't remember
the [__] that happened in between but
you just you just have pictures good God
Almighty was that a bad looking pizza is
there anything [__] worse than that
just a bad looking it's just you know
let's you know when someone makes a
pizza right and it even sucks when it's
hot but then it just sits there
for a while and it just gets that that
cold case file look to it you know what
I mean like it should have a [__] toe
tag hanging off the crust they brought
over a whole pie that looked like that
you know they look like some
five-year-old made it in like an
easy-bake oven you know and you're their
parents now you have to eat it and say
oh wow Suzie it's delicious
you know just begin begin her little
life of people lying to her not being
[__] honest saying no don't wear that
you look fat in that now you just go oh
Susie you look beautiful
that's an excellent pizza you made you
want Susie it [__] sucks all right
I'm not saying to give up your dream
about being a cook but you definitely
don't [__] have any Talent at this
point your life you know maybe we can
send you to some sort of oh Jesus Christ
what are those chef schools called huh
well what is that art called you know
come on you know what it is because with
us see it's not custodial it's not Comus
Eric he plays for [__] the Canadians
Oh Canadians I want to say bonjour to
all my friends up there in Montreal you
know it's just breaking your balls I've
been blogging for the Bruins and is
basically I went down was blogging for
the Bruins during the playoffs which I'm
going to continue to do because they
swept the Montreal Canadiens and
basically you know I have to blog for
the Bruins of playing the Canadiens I
mean what am I going to say Canadiens
won 24 cups we've only won five we
haven't won since 1972 all I can do is
just try to piss you off that's all I
was doing
I said Montreal fans got really really
[__] mad you know I made fun of their
coach I just did like you know I just
made fun all they looked how they boo
their [__] players I don't anymore
and I said I was just trying to be a
jerk and people got all fun as noisy
well hockey you know this guy calls
himself a comedian I don't think this is
very funny whatever you know what's
[__] funny
I heard Celine Dion is thinking about
buying the Montreal Canadiens it's
probably moving to Vegas
be a [__] mascot on ice that would be
that would be a crime that would be a
goddamn crime all right this is the
Monday morning podcast this is the
hungover episode of the Monday morning
podcast I am sitting in a hotel in
Manhattan New York why are you doing
that bill huh you laying low after your
weekend of boozing now I got a week at
Caroline's and working with Joe DeRosa
once again my partner in crime
two codependent [__] alcoholics do
you know what time I think I might have
told this story on ona Opie and Anthony
show for you uh people who live in I
don't know [__] North Dakota um I
don't want that I was in Caroline's
Caroline's comedy club on Broadway where
I will be Thursday Friday Saturday and
Sunday for a [__] 22 shows 22 [__]
shows I can't even do one show at this
point I'm laying low man I'm laying low
um but anyways one night I was I was
standing there at the bar and I decided
I didn't know if I decided I wasn't
going to drink but I just wasn't
drinking you know and all of a sudden
who comes walking down the stairs you
know like some starlet in the 1950s
making a big [__] debut Joe DeRosa he
was missing was the [__] the evening
gown he comes [__] waltz and down the
stairs you know all dainty like and the
second I saw him I was like ass [__] now
I got a drink right and you know what he
was thinking the exact same thing that
was a funny thing neither one of us
wanted to drink you got any friends like
that you just you just been fuck-ups for
so long that neither one you can just
pull you out of the tailspin I'm sure
anybody was in a a good tell me what
what exactly that that's called what
kind of friendship that is um I don't
[__] know I I really I really really
feel like [__] right now and so I'm
setting the room and you notice the
quality might be a little bit better I
actually got a microphone now and I have
a little mixer and I have my headphones
on and I'm sitting here in the [__]
dark that's not true I got the one
little desk light on basically talking
to myself you know technically once you
start listening this whole thing makes
sense
but right now before I upload this thing
this is really uh you know this is why
they don't give everybody handguns
because if one was laying around I'm
[__] with you you know what I would
do I'd probably pointed out the window I
wouldn't shoot anybody just try to scare
someone maybe make me laugh and I could
get a little oxygen or something into my
[__] head what do you guys what do
you guys use for hangovers huh other
than the smart thing not drink anymore
goddamn it's just so much fun though you
know having a great time you know
there's broads
you know just having a good [__] time
just a good time you know
so the [__] people who like to drink
I met a couple of hunters I'm at a
couple of dancers I'm at you know I met
a you know nice mix of people that I'm a
[__] weird dude man I don't like
people before I get on stage like I
don't want to see them I don't see
anybody in the [__] crowd but the
second the show's over if somebody's
cool that's the part of the show I enjoy
and I become like this [__] Charlie
Rose and I just started interviewing
people you know what's it like to shoot
a pheasant in the face huh what's that
like you know do you got a little
[__] a couple of pieces of wood that
you rub together and somehow it sounds
like a pheasant going eh Eddie come on
over here you know or whatever [__]
pheasants names are if you had a present
what would you name it huh Larry that'd
be a great name for a pheasant that'd be
funny Jay had it right people looking at
it
oh my god is it a present like Larry get
the [__] off of that thing actually got
off of it you know and then you got on a
late-night talk show and then you went
out there and then it didn't work and
then the host sort of mugged about how
it didn't work and then maybe takes a
turd on his [__] wingtip shoe and 50
years later it's part of the Greatest
Hits DVD you know and little did you
know that that was the pinnacle your
life as a [__] zookeeper that one
moment you thought it was going to keep
happening nope one episode one Episode
you never asked back because your animal
[__] on the [__] host shoe wasn't
supposed to do that
it didn't do they didn't do it in the
rehearsals
all right how the [__] am I going to
maneuver this here all the rattling in
the background gonna move my mixer are
you know I feel right now I feel like
the [__] Unabomber
all this goddamn was he anti technology
though I don't know if he was anti or
Pro at all I know he was definitely
[__] alone
and was a paranoid son of a [__] my
back there we go you guys get nervous
there for a second what the [__] there's
too many [__] cords here I'm gonna go
back to this cell phone I'm not holding
my [__] laptop like a goddamn you
know you know servants used to hand [__]
to kings would they put something on a
pillow and then they had their little
hands underneath it that's why I'm
holding it I'll tell you what can I
paint a [__] picture can I paint a
goddamn picture let me let me adjust the
microphone I want to tell you about my
microphone by the way do you remember
back in the 1970s you know nowadays
whenever somebody has a mic and they
have like a little filter or not a
filter whatever I don't know the techno
you know little spongy thing that you
stick on there so it doesn't pop or if
there's some sort of wind you know
nowadays they're just black and it just
looks like a you know [__] giant [__]
just sitting there right something that
they can put on TV you know but back in
the day man the 70s you know when people
were buying weed by the [__] garbage
bag full and you know the 70s were
colorful man you [__] day just
started off you know they had that crazy
serial that they used to have somebody
brought up boo berry or Count Chocula
and Franken berry and I was in the
cereal aisle you know the other day well
when I went to Trader Joe's when I was
gonna have a healthy week before I down
five bottles of whiskey
I'm the worst drunk too I'm one of those
guys I [__] call up people and start
telling them I love them yeah one of
those guys you know III do everything
but end up in the drunk tank on the
[__] Andy Griffith Show I'm such an
old school drunk but I'm not an angry
guy when I get drunk I'm really not I'm
actually Pleasant I'm able to remote is
that why you do it bill I don't [__]
know all I know is it makes me feel like
[__] the [__] was I
just talking about oh how cold color for
the 70s were yeah you'd start off with
that [__] cereal that they had and
one of the worst sentences ever yeah he
started off with that cereal that they
had oh there you go bill it's a great
way to [__] start it off right if you
pat yourself on the back about how you
could paint a visual you know it's funny
I have headphones on right now I have no
idea how a lot I'm talking I'm sure that
there is somebody on the other side of
this wall that is contemplating calling
the front desk but what they're
listening to is so [__] bizarre they
haven't been able to tap out yet um well
that's arrogant bill maybe they're
listening and you sound [__] annoying
all right what else stop heckling
yourself get to the point yeah you start
off when you eat tricks you need boo
bury the [__] literally change the
colour Ian milk which is some really
hacky comedy from [__] the 80s but
I'm telling you you had that [__] going
on Honeycomb
you know the color [__] people were
wearing polyester I mean [__] was loud
in the 70s you know those plaid slacks
he liked slacks he had boots that set up
the side they were all [__] shiny
women had like those those plastic
looking purses it was [__] freaky was
weird everything was like done suddenly
I think that the advertisers just like
look everybody's on drugs so we we
really need to enhance their trip so
much [__] in the 70s was like really
done - even like the [__] monkeys
which I guess you know was that the
stuff was the late 60s I think it went
to the early 70s everyone when they used
to [__] you know pretend to sing and
pretend to play instruments at the end
of the show there and they would they
would cut to their little musical
montages and they'd always do like half
the time they would do like those they
put it in like a kaleidoscope so you had
them actually in the middle and then
like six of them like going around like
a [__] like a [__] revolver so I
don't know what it was and you're eating
that cereal you just watching this [__]
anyways this all comes around to my
microphone back then you couldn't even
watch like a sports show without sort
but you know what I mean like they had
ABC's Wide World of Sports and they had
these [__] bright yellow sport coats
on and I used to have these microphones
and when they stood outside the little
spongy thing that they stuck on top
wasn't black it didn't blend in with the
microphone there were these crazy colors
and one that I always remember was there
was always like bright orange it made no
[__] sense but as a kid I liked it so
whatever I bought a microphone and the
guy goes what kind of windscreen do you
want you know you want the standard
black one I said [__] that I want that
one Keith Jackson used to use when he do
Monday Night Football way back in the
day or we do the college games remember
Keith Jackson huh hello again everybody
this is Keith Jackson remember that guy
Alabama Crimson Tide and [__]
Wolverines at Michigan they're gonna be
swapping pink um anyways yeah so that's
what I got here it was a really long
[__] way to go to explain that I put
an orange spongy thing in the end of my
[__] mic and I'm a Jew I know I'm
cursing a lot right now and I'm cursing
I'm not cursing at you guys okay
sometimes people get confused it's not
cursing at me I'm not cursing you I'm
cursin at my hangover so I described
[__] to you
all right Jesus Christ look at this
[__] fake wood in this desk this is
the kind of desk that you sit you know
that you sit at when you're like
confessing to a murder you know what I
mean you just sitting in there trying to
wear you down you bring in some food
acting like they're your friends I was
just watching those [__] Cold Case
Files man those things are creepy just
[__] creepy just watching the people
when they come in in the na and they
they get in question for the murder and
they just sound like you know regular
regular guys where were you that night
oh you know was home you know watching a
basketball game you know you chill it
out had a pee to find out he [__]
hacks up 23 people and when they won
then when they admit it they're like oh
yeah yeah I did it you know they found
this one guy that that was that [__]
guy the Green River I don't know I
always got to give them nicknames the
[__]
Jews so they can sell more papers they
give nicknames like they're going to the
Rose Bowl or some [__] you know Crazy
Legs Johnson he's killed 48 [__]
people they call him the Iceman um
anyways so there there's one guy up in
Seattle right he killed all these all
these women was brutal and they picked
the guy up he'd never been arrested
before and they they they meet him
outside of his job because they put
together a case okay he has no idea that
they're on to him they got they the cops
come up to the guy and they say listen
buddy we're you know [__] whatever
the police officers I just got a
headache I don't want the [__] they say
you know they say hi we're cops and
we're here to arrest you for the murder
of four women now if he never been
arrested before when your heart drop the
guy just is like yeah evidently he just
went oh okay then they brought him down
there he confessed to that and he
confessed to like [__] 60 other women
that he had killed so they bring this
guy into another room to talk to it to a
psychologist you know because he wants
to try to break him down so he can
figure out so you can stop these maniacs
right and they asked the guy this
question they said you know if you could
um if you could pick out one thing about
your personality that you feel is
different from the average person
walking down the street what would that
be and without missing a beat the guy
said that that whole caring thing Wow
you know when you think you don't give a
[__] Jesus Christ just rag off yeah the
whole Karen Donald Carrington yeah I
just don't seem to give a [__] it's
weird you know I don't know I hate
watching that's I don't know why I watch
that show it show literally gives me
nightmares you know what I mean you
start thinking about what this is not
funny the [__] am i talking about see
this is what happens this is what
happens when you go out boozing you know
the sad thing is is I know at some point
at some point this weekend I'm probably
going to do this again but fortunately
I'm in New York City so I won't end up
at a Steak and Shake I've never eaten
there I think I've made fun of that
[__] place
on these podcasts how would you rate how
would you guys out there huh all my
listeners out there please tell me you
listen and please tell me I'm not I'm
not just sitting here baking under this
[__] hotel lamp for nothing how would
you rate the worst your worst like fast
food you know what I mean everybody you
know no one wants to eat it but we all
need it because you know it tastes good
[__] tastes good but then there's
certain ones either you had if you had a
bad experience or you just a look of it
you know I gotta say for me like Taco
Bell I just can't go in there there's
just something about the colors on the
sign it just makes my stomach hurt you
know you get that awful feeling in your
stomach you know I feel the same way
about like RVs you've never [__] with
the Arby's I'm a McDonald's guy I'm old
school like McDonald's in and out of
this [__] but you know I got a lot of
memories as a kid at McDonald's so I
think that one still wins even though in
and out is even better but there's just
certain ones I want you to go into you
know all right guys I'm [__] fading
fast Jesus Christ I need a [__] water
or something the hell did I do with that
water didn't I have water around here
hang on a second that Jesus Christ
[__] water I should head last night
all right let's get on with the
questions here if you're new to my page
you probably think I'm out of my [__]
mind and you would be right I am out of
my mind but you know what you know what
I don't have any say to that I have
guilty as charged
what are you [__] perfect once you go
to [__] wwm [__] perfect calm and go
listen to that podcast if I says a lot
of [__] laughs on that one you know do
they got a mixer I got a [__] mixer
[__] you like that [__] I'm learning a
lot of computer stuff you know what how
much you guys make me computer literate
can you do that for me I'll start off
with something really easy something
that really [__] annoys me on my
computer and you know what maybe someone
else does this is maybe this annoys
someone else who has a computer who
also has a drinking problem okay and
then uh you know I'll read how to do it
I mean I can help another drunk out
there alright this is one of my problems
that I have when I go to you when I go
into Apple works right the text is so
[__] small I don't understand it it's
set I know how to change it but I got to
change it every time alright right now
it's stuck on twelve okay
which is basically squinch size and you
know when I copy and paste you guys
emails into my [__] thing it's it
makes it smaller I don't know what it's
doing I wanted at eighteen I want the
default set at eighteen how the [__] do
I do that in Apple works I got a brand
new MacBook I want to learn how to do
that okay I want to learn some [__] you
know I know how to upload I know how to
do this now
look at me I'm gonna upload [__] I'll
turn it into a [__] mp3 I'll send it
right to you I know how to do that now I
feel great
it's my new opening line when I hit on
chicks on the road you know what's up
sweetie are you doing you like the show
you know I can also upload audio files
and turn them into an mp3 huh put it on
the desktop
I'll [__] drag it right over there
same way I'm gonna drag you across the
[__] carpet in my hotel what the [__]
is that
alright can somebody teach me how to do
that please okay and let's get on with
the podcast here you know what the
problem is is there's not enough [__]
room here well I got it why don't I just
move this dude I even have a little
stand here for my microphone I have a
little [__] stand this is like I
don't know this is one of these like
really nerdy things that if you start
when you're 18 by the time you're 30
you're famous and you're not a nerd
anymore like chicks want to [__] you
it's um it's unreal but when you start
this at 40 it's just pathetic and said
okay here we go we're going to go to uh
I already did the underrated so why
don't I do over it I know this is really
this is really coming off grumpy
I understand but whatever you know last
week I was pissed
this week I'm grumpy you know what I'm
due for a happy one
about next week next week I'll be all
bubbly no I won't because I'll be flying
across this country man that's gonna
suck let's not think about that do you
know like I literally fall asleep on the
plane I've flown across this country so
many [__] times that I can literally
look down and pretty much guess what
state I'm over you know as a passenger I
can do that why these levels so low but
the [__] is going on there we go am I
not talking into this thing hello test
there we go you know I mean I can look
out I can tell you know pretty good I
mean Rick I don't know wait a minute
what the [__] am i bragging about when
Southwest is a desert you get into
Colorado you got the mountains starts
getting flat you're like all right it's
abrasca Kansas maybe we're into Iowa you
start seeing more lights you're moving
towards [__] into Illinois right that
how it works
I don't [__] know like I actually
like I recognize like lakes now you know
I can look down on my watch now you know
what's taking this long we're right
about here and we should be seeing
Cleveland coming but there it is
there it is I look down sometimes a look
at [__] stadiums fill my [__] life
is now if I could be outside the plane
and look at my stupid round head looking
out of that little oval [__] window
this is what I signed up for this is how
[__] hungover I am I'm actually
bitching that I'm a comedian something
that I wanted to do something that I
decided to do all right Jesus Christ
there was a way for you guys that email
me a [__] tampon I I think I get like
9 million this week all right ah here we
go let's read the overrated all right
let's get into your thoughts I think
you've heard enough from me for one week
all right
overrated bill all right build I think
this is overrated a lot of people don't
talk about this this is coming from a
woman she says male strippers are
overrated
she said especially when they are hired
for a bachelorette party is it me or
does uh Jesus Christ I can't
when I'm [__] not hungover she goes
visit me or does anyone else think this
is the stupidest waste of 125 bucks
they've ever seen you guys get strippers
105 bucks Jesus is there anything that
sucks about being a woman yeah
giving birth periods all right you're
right you're right sorry
yeah I can't even think it back this
yeah the guys are all the guys were all
muscled up and everything but to be
honest when you see women looking at
male strippers and they are hooting and
hollering and laughing and laughing it
up with their girlfriends they're
actually laughing at the stripper yes it
is true that they are likely some women
who enjoy it and thinking this guy would
probably be awesome in bed but 95% of
women are hysterically laughing at the
ridiculous man all oiled up in his
g-string with his stupid little boom box
playing INXS what you need Jesus Christ
they add she just there you go she's
painting a picture there that's what you
need a good story and you need a
narrator he's not [__] grumpy and
hungover
anyways playing what you need gyrating
around the living room and dry humping
dad's lazy boy you know what Jesus
Christ uh
bla bla bla bla bla this is really
[__] long let me get to the point
here she says women what women want is
women want a man who was a man kill
spiders drink beer etc none of us would
picture our man acting like a sex
machine with a wax chest dancing in
front of a group of housewives a man
will offer my girlf man will offer my
girlfriend is a stripper and he knows
his buddies will congratulate him my god
dude would you go friends a stripper
that's awesome
a woman would never offer the same
information why because she knows the
response to mother woman would be a
snicker and a yike gee I'm so sorry look
is that true the women really not like
don't just like Cougars don't they like
male strippers you know if you want to
know what it's like to be a guy be a
woman and you as far as like our sex
drive you know I think maybe a woman
once you're in your 40s or that
demanding what the [__] point I'm trying
to make there I
know that like older women act like the
same level of [__] that guys act
like our entire [__] lives when they
start to get older I don't know what it
is I guess it's safe they finally don't
give a [__] and they can admit that they
like [__] or they like sex you know
because before they have to be like well
you know it's just for procreation
alright just like my boyfriend's [__] I
don't have any other [__] fantasies
you know
where's guys we just get we just get to
be pigs we just get to be the goddamn
pigs that we are but you know what you
get to cry at movies and get that [__]
out I got to hold it in you know that
was a rough one was that Harvey Milk
movie the amount of [__] I had to think
about so I wouldn't tear up during that
movie just so I wouldn't be feel you
know as a guy you can't [__] cry so I
got to sit there really you know he's
going through some [__] I know everyone
was getting all sad when uh you know
when he gets whacked there you know so
in order not to get emotional myself I
just thought you know what if someone
just came home and just kicked him right
in the balls and I just start laughing
you know that's what it is
that's what comedy is it's just stop
from crying alright uh number two oh
this is oh my god this New Yorkers
aren't gonna like this one this is
another thing she says is overrated is
underrated actually a two-run homer in
the bottom of the ninth ninth after
merry off of Mariano Rivera and I could
have [__] read that better yeah the
Red Sox swept the Yankees man is [__]
unbelievable
they'll be back this [__] always happens
one team always jumps out in front of
the other team right and then we do we
fo can all you guys we [__] all you
girls and then they literally almost
like it's fixed now the Yankees will
sweep us down there and we'll play each
other like 12 times or 13 times and
someone will win that win it [__]
seven to six
it's a goddamn business people okay
there's no [__] Santa Claus I don't
buy it and we stole home plate - [__]
does that happen 200 million dollar team
you know something you realize the Red
Sox they're only there
number four this year as far as money
spent oh yeah a lot of you [__]
didn't know that did you
Yankee spent 200 million then it's the
Mets then I believe the Cubs and then us
were 122 million is that great now we
can act like we're some little [__]
starving panty little pansy [__] team
Yankee Jay ruin in baseball um who gives
a [__] I say what's funny is of the the
[__] did I just do there
mess it on my computer all right let's
well you know I'm really starting to
feel like I'm losing the momentum of
this 31 minutes 31 hungover minutes dude
I'm gonna tell you right now this is
feeling like four hours I feel like I'm
doing a [__] telethon right now let's
get to the questions for the week I got
a I got one here am I the only one who
thinks Terry Francona's glasses make him
look like a cancer stricken mrs. Claus
he's the he's the UH he's the manager of
the product I did Sam yeah those state
they're definitely he looks like he
should be at the very least you know
going out caroling or something reading
the night before Christmas I don't
[__] know I don't know you know I
talked a lot about sports last week and
a couple people really got this just
talking about how dumb they are some guy
senses this huge [__] rant about
saying how you know being into a sports
team is almost as dumb as patriotism I
know the point you're trying to make you
know what I mean I get it you know I
know what you're saying but you know
what the [__] dude I mean I've done like
almost two years of these things
eventually Sports was going to come up
we always have to talk about what you
want to talk about this guy was really I
don't know sometimes I don't know if
people are going for douche bag of the
week I don't know what do I have
anything else here I don't think I have
anything else Oh bill I need some advice
all right here's another guy obviously
had some Jameson listen to this [__]
this is his question hey Bill
big fan bombed right now I didn't get
that for a second it doesn't like he
said big fan and he meant like that line
bomb but evidently means he's shit-faced
or he's the worst speller anyway in the
world here we go
it starts off it says anyways
some objective viewpoint me and this hot
chick I'm a big old ugly rugby player
recently started hanging out he
misspelled that and we like noe he put
the e at the beginning of each we like
each a lot Jason Kreis dude
recently started hanging out we like
each other a lot my problem she used to
date a black guy I have black friends my
buddies will tear me apart thoughts
advice thanks John
well John um my thoughts are you're
pretty [__] shit-faced when you when
you sent that email that's my thoughts
because the rest of it makes no sense
you used to date a black guy okay you
have black friends is that supposed to
establish that you're not racist my
buddies will tear me apart like what
they're gonna in a good-natured way rib
you that your dick isn't going to be as
big I don't know what you're trying to
say here tell you what why don't you
[__] you know don't email me now
because I know you're feeling the way
I'm feeling but you know sober up try to
clean that up you know I think maybe you
got something there send me a second
draft I don't know what the [__] that
means she used to date a black guy how
the [__] would they know you had black
friends my buddy with you your black
friends do they know this guy did she
use to date one of the one of your
friends who's black that's just a weird
statement I have black friends do you
have black friends sure we all do like
you're trying to loan yourself some sort
of credit credibility the [__] does that
mate anyways you know how many friends
do I have Joe DeRosa he's half Egyptian
so it takes care of the does that take
care of Arabs or jibsen is considered
air I know what the [__] Arabs are I
don't even know I'll [__] know okay
you know I don't know I don't it is
being innocent one question I was is
being Jewish is that oh I know it's a
religion is it or is it a
race it's not race right I don't want to
tell long time ago I was in high school
and one of my friends was Jewish right
and I said to him I said what are you
Italian
he goes no I'm Jewish I can tell I
offended him so I didn't do a follow-up
question but in my head I'm going okay
Italian is a race I thought Jewish was a
religion I know Jewish is a religion you
know did that make any [__] sense I
don't [__] know let's let's read a
revenge story let's read a revenge story
and let's [__] wrap up this podcast
this is going to be a shorter one this
is the hungover version always something
else I came up with is I'm actually
contributing under 80 you know it's
underrated free internet and the hotels
goddamn and I like that I wrote all that
other [__] in anger so let's not read
that all right here's a big long revenge
story to end the podcast this week and
let me know that what you guys think
about this sound I know kind of a turn
in my head a little bit and I got this
mic like stationaries that's affecting
the sound because God knows I'm not
going to go back and listen to all this
[__] I usually listen to them but not
this week man not this week's gonna for
a [__] week I don't what to tell you
you know there's all these time so it's
great I don't have a kid you know
because I would have no patience for him
you know it's a new bit I've been
working on in my act talking about how
much I like I like kids when they're I
like kids the same way like I like dogs
I like I like them when they're puppies
and they're full of life you know once
they get a little bit older and Stuber
and they think they know [__] it's just
it's [__] they're annoying you know I
like kids like you know what [__]
cracks me up I saw this kid the other
day this kid was like 2 years old right
you guys funny about toddlers right how
they did I talked about this already how
they got their little [__] they got
their you have a beer belly and they
never even drank they look you know they
look these little [__] truckers it
always is just [__] makes me toddlers
[__] beer bellies just [__] make
me laugh every time I say you know it's
because they're not self-conscious about
their bodies they don't give a [__] so
they just got it hanging out there like
some [__] drunken
love at a barbecue you know they just
funny to me they look like they've
already fed they [__] up in life you
know like they're gambling they're
eating the wrong food I don't know why
do they have those fat bellies Jesus
Christ you're eating mush and milk
you're the first well I just admit I
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about sometimes I'm literally sweating
right now because of a lamp that's how
[__] hungover I am okay here we go
you know something else I hate I mean
this is something I've been doing I've
been I've been trying to eat you know
one just veggie meal a day you know so
then I can make up for the [__] oxen
and I'm going to eat later on that night
or evidently the [__] steak and shake
that I'm going to eat and you know I
can't stand about those [__] veggie
meals I ordered this veggie meal right
I ordered a some sort of [__]
horrific veggie wrap which really sucks
because they grilled the vegetables you
know it's like when you go beyond where
they start becoming mushy it just I
can't even say what it sounds like what
is what it tasted like because it's
going to make me [__] gag here but
you know it's just I'm going to do it
you know what if you're squeamish cover
your [__] ears right now you know
what it tastes like when you they over
steamed vegetables or they [__] over
grill I don't know what it gets all
squishy and mushy it tastes like it's
pre-chewed just pausing right now
waiting for the groans people throwing
their headphones off
all you people on ellipticals on did you
just grown to the Hat the fat hairy [__]
next to you start looking at you
wondering what you listening to this is
what I hate you order a veggie wrap all
right they go one veggie wrap I ordered
some soup like an old [__] Jewish man
in Manhattan right and I don't know what
happens they bring it to me and this
they got french fries on the side it's I
can't you see I'm trying I'm trying to
get in shape
I understand it's a french fry it's a
potato which is a vegetable I get it
what the [__] it's like when you go to
the Cheesecake Factory you order salad
and then they go would you like to start
it's like do you not get the [__]
theme here lady you not see what I'm
trying to do you see my bloated
alcohol-infused face do you understand
what I'm trying to do here actually you
know it's not even fair because I
actually talked to one of those
cheesecake I think I was making fun of
the Cheesecake Factory and I'm I act and
there actually was there was a waitress
in the crowd as always I always end up
[__] on something and then someone
from the crowd is like hey I do that
what the [__] so it was his Cheesecake
Factory waitress and she came up to me
and she said uh she goes actually they
make us do that we have to do that if we
don't do it we get fired
really is that what it's come down to
yes that's where the decisions in your
life lend you that you have a job that
if you don't ask people for cake which
is usually a nice [__] thing to do if
you don't do it you get fired they have
a gun to your [__] head to basically
have your job to try to make people
become diabetics is that what's going on
is that what happened in your life
because you sucked at something in
school you know [__] all right let's
get on with the revenge story
I am [__] I know why I shut off the
air conditioners anybody else just hate
air conditioning I don't mind air
conditioning when it's 9,000 degrees out
but when it's [__] you know it's like
I don't know what it is it's like 65
degrees out 70 72 and they got the air
conditioning on it's like are you trying
to give me pneumonia huh is that what
the [__] you're trying to do Jesus
Christ am I in a mood hey what do you
guys think about that swine flu you know
this might be a little controversial but
I'm kind of all for it I think this is
another time where we're we're getting
in the way of nature running its course
nature is trying to kill off us
not all of us but some of us so that you
know there's no traffic you know what I
mean it's like the forest fire it's a
rebirth
you know you burn it down some animals
dies some trees die you get rid of all
the brush it's like a spring cleaning
that's all a plague is it's just that we
you know you don't want any loved ones
to die plagues and I'll tell you meant
plagues that they're really uh they're
fascinating like they're putting out all
these stats you know [__] this revenge
story let me go on the internet here let
me we let me restart Firefox now what is
your [__] problem I never stopped it
I'm in the middle of a podcast got damn
these [__] computers what did I do
this [__] to me come on let's go anyways
yeah they were given up all these uh all
these statistics on plagues and that
type of stuff evidently did you know
like like six hundred and seventy five
thousand people died in the United
States in nineteen eighteen because of
like an influenza whatever the [__] that
is I know what the [__] that is but
everybody got it and a whole bunch of
people died and you know what's [__]
you know what's [__] up about that was
thank God they did you know because if
they didn't they all would have [__]
and they would have made more [__] P
we might have been where we're at right
now we might have been them you know 15
years earlier although I just throw
numbers out man like I'm a [__]
scientist here know what I'm talking
about
hang on a second let's look up plagues
it's gonna give me on some sort of FBI
list you know I need to do now is Google
[__] anthrax and they'll be a knock
at my door and I really will be
confessing at this [__] table here
great plagues in history ok this should
be a great game show
that's that be a [__] great game show
okay is you tried it you start googling
[__] and whoever gets the FBI to
come to your place first wins and you
can't do like easy [__] like like
obviously any sort of creepy pedophile
stuff because that's just [__]
horrific it's it's never funny is it you
know I joke about it on stage sometime
all right
list of historical plagues let's go to
Wikipedia god knows they're always
number one alright in human history the
term plague refers to an epidemic
disease causing a high rate of mortality
a pestilence and academic - shut the
[__] up I want to I want stats okay what
I go to the MLB gotta go CBS Sports calm
so I got to go on going danger great
plagues of Athens let's get to some
recent ones here you know what do we got
here great plague of Iceland see you
know saying everywhere everybody had a
plague in it then the heard great plague
of Portugal great plague of Russia great
plague of Ireland Scotland London plague
just attacked a [__] city for two
years 1592 - 1590 for the Italian plague
everybody's [__] had one last time we
had a plague you know you just say that
you just can nip it in the butt with
with with [__] with the media they
just they get it out there before it
gets a chance - to help with the traffic
you know so I'm in New York City right
now and they they have a number of
number of cases out in Queens and you
know they're telling people how you know
it's funny how they tell people to use
common sense if you feel like you're
getting the flu go to the hospital right
so they say you know if you sneeze or if
you cough just cover your mouth right so
a half hour later I'm walking down the
street walking down whatever [__]
Avenue here in New York and I see this
kid on a bicycle and he proceeds to
sneeze and he just turns his head and it
looked like a [__] spit-take and i
just bursted out laughing bursted out
laughing you know rather than being I'm
like the exact opposite of a
going to say a hemophiliac that's not
what I'm trying to say one of those
[__] people that always nervous that
they got something a hysterectomy what
is it I know it begins with an H this
always happens to me it's what happens
to my [__] brain as I knew the word
and that my brain panics and all I'm
left with is a letter uh [__]
hemophilia I can't get that word out of
my head you know what I got to talk
about something else let's talk about
the Jonas Brothers comedy show huh I
think I speak for the group when I say
it's about time you know because their
music is [__] hilarious and I just
you know the [__] [__]
it's [__] business you know what I
mean really is that what I should that's
not what I should have done I should
have gotten this business with [__]
3m three of my other brothers you know
I'll play the drums you get a ukulele
and then you do this and then you'll get
your own [__] sketch show sons of
[__] oh yeah I am bitter I'm bitter
about the [__] Jonas Brothers I want
some goddamn stats here on dead people
all right I don't feel good so I want to
read about dead people make all the
Black Death here we go here we go the
black death was one of the deadliest
pandemics the [__] is a pandemic there's
an epidemic and a pandemic a pandemic is
an epidemic of infectious disease that
spreads through populations across their
large region for instance a continent or
even worldwide Thank You Wikipedia so
what the [__] is an epidemic is what
happens and you just start [__]
searching everything and then you forget
what the hell an epidemic occurs when
new cases of a certain disease occur in
a given human population during a given
period isn't that the same [__] thing
is that not the same [__] thing
close enough all right you guys want to
hear about the Black Death huh when
you're sitting there in your cubicle at
work well goddamn it I'm going to read
you some [__] God knows you could do
this yourself it's right there in
Wikipedia the black death was according
to chronicles characterized by
buboes a swelling in the lymph nodes I
don't even know where the lymph nodes
are I think there are they in your neck
a hypochondriac BAM I got it alright see
that's what I got to do just start
talking about other [__] then I don't
know where I yell out the word and now I
can't remember what I was talking about
all I know I'm the exact opposite of a
hypochondriac where now that doesn't
make sense I poke Andreea because
nervous like to keep my IUD apples
scientists and historians at the
beginning of the 20th century assumed
that the black death was an outbreak of
the same disease caused by the bacterium
who gives a [__] and spread by fleas
with the help of animals like the black
rat however this view has recently been
give me some stats for Christ's sake how
many [__] people died what wait wait
a minute
the origins of the plague is that that's
Deb Dee badoo badoo the total number of
deaths worldwide is estimated at 75
million people approximately 25 to 50
million of which occurred in Europe the
Black Death is estimated to have killed
30% to 60% of Europe's population just
think about that people 6 out of 10
automobiles that you'll see in front of
you tonight as you try and drive home
would not [__] be there and we
already built the highways to hold you
know a ton of [__] car you know what
I'm saying
you know it's America man you want to
[__] Drive put the top down then I'm
making Pontiacs anymore how [__] sad
is that let's think about some great
Pontiacs that's what we're going to
close up as we talked about the epidemic
we talked about death let's talk about
how sad it is that there's no more
Pontiacs anymore there's just no more
the Pontiac trans-am huh kind of drops
off after that but you know the Sunbird
the t1000 you guys remember the Pontiac
t1000 house when you're really [__] up
when you bought a bootleg Chevette
that's when you really were saying that
you were an extra level of white trash
okay you ate macaroni and cheese five
times a [__] week you know you know I
can't even what the [__] I've sivan said
today right was I riffing about sharing
a tray of macaroni cheese with another
man looking into his eyes was that this
podcast was that another podcast was
that at some point is show last night I
don't know what but it's been the Monday
morning podcast for April [__]
twenty-something I don't know what it is
I don't know this is we're into garbage
time they still have their as well their
official site is still up when I want to
Pontiac so they have the Bonneville you
know what they were a one-trick pony
anybody drive a Pontiac I don't know but
let's talk about that next week okay
this is the Monday morning podcast I'd
be a caroline's this week and then I'm
taking a break here for May and June
gonna recharge my [__] batteries and
coming out swinging in July start at the
Comedy Works in Denver and then I go to
Eddie's fist-fuck in [__] Yuma I'm
just gonna make up [__] now and then I'm
going to be at wallpaper Freddy's at the
limelight beautiful theater where Cirque
de Soleil performed just reading awful
brochures here what is Cirque de Soleil
I really impressed with the strength
that those guys have not so much on the
costumes all right you guys that's the
podcast for this week I hope you guys
all have a tremendous week and I
apologize if I was a little bit grumpy
this week but you know I'm sorry all
right
that's on me I'm just going to palm
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]